أتذكر أنني كنت في السابعة من عمري
أشاهد كأس العالم وذهبت فرنسا
إلى النهائيات وكنت من أشد المعجبين
بفرنسا - من أشد المعجبين بزين الدين السودان
وقد وقعت في حب طريقة لعبه
بالكرة وكنت مثل أوه أنا  أريد أن
ألعب ، أحب قول الكعب العالي لأنني فقط
شيء تعرفه ، الشيء الحار هو
شيء أحب
إثباته وتحسينه وتجريب شيء جديد ، لذا
نعم أرادت أمي أن تكون
لاعبة كرة قدم ولا يمكنها لعب كرة القدم
لأنها  لم تكن العائلة تريد أن
جدي لم يرغب في ذلك ، فعندما
علمت أنني أريد أن ألعب كرة القدم ، كانت
مثل Go Go Ahead ،
لذا بصفتي امرأة في كرة القدم أو كريستا
، كان الأمر مختلفًا تمامًا
، أعتقد أنه ليس شيئًا
يمكنك أن ترى الآن يمكنك رؤية المزيد ولكن
قبل 20 عامًا في عام 2007 عندما بدأت
ألعب مع الفريق ، كنت الفتاة الوحيدة
في الفريق
[موسيقى]
ألعب ضد sin vault الذي ألعب به مع
Drake الذي ألعب معه وغير ذلك الكثير  كثير من
الناس ويمكنك أن ترى أن كرة واحدة فقط
يمكن أن تجلب الكثير  من الناس معًا
إذا كان هناك شخص واحد أرغب
في عدم جعله بيونسيه ، فأنا لا أعرف ما إذا
كانت من محبي كرة القدم ولكني
أود فقط مقابلتها للتحدث
معها وعدم جعل ذلك ضخمًا
[موسيقى  ]